you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's try 9 C 6 and see if
we get a scotch or a rel apes' all right
we'll go with Knight to f6 and I guess
Bishop e7
takes takes takes I have Queen here now
that that's defended maybe this is the
point where I play d6
to go with the d4 this knight is pinned
it's a bit unusual
83 hmm I haven't seen that one
all right I'm threatening now to take
and then follow up with this so I have
to go 9 2 D 2
Wow they're really allowing you this
mover we're not playing crazy house I've
seen crazy house variations where you
allow this you take and then I'm Bishop
takes Queen there's night here in
regular chess so sure about that
let's consider here I have a pin how
could I really exploit this pin well
well I think I want to hmm
let's go with King here and my idea is
to play for f5 so this I'm still gonna
try to stay on the f3 pawn so I'm gonna
look to move my knight and then play for
f5 I'd really like to see this okay well
I wonder if I have to you know let's
let's take a timeout for this now on a
queen exchange then the king is gonna
have to step up to g2
hmm okay maybe okay interesting just
dropping the bishop back now what I
don't like is that there's some pressure
against this guy hmm I feel like I
should be repositioning my night right
around this point let's try that now I
really want to be able to do this but I
run into some tactical issues oh it's
not expecting that let's start with this
move least mass the bishops view of h7
because if I trade too many rooks at the
end I could lose this pawn and maybe a
good point right now is to do this move
and look at the c-4 square so much for
having this idea of taking advantage of
this pawn okay
well I could exchange first let's do
that and then I could drop into c4 let's
do that on rook takes rook I'll take
with the bishop
keep him defended and maybe even try for
this stuff so let's see I want ISO on my
King already on g8 but uh yeah he's got
a ways to go
stuck in the corner I could even can
okay is now the time to just well maybe
I should capture here Oh
Bishop takes Knight though let's
consider Bishop takes Knight hmm around
Knight takes bishop Knight takes bishop
pawn takes pawn takes pawn takes Bishop
d6 92 is otherwise this is painful
I really like my knight though I really
like my knight on c4 yeah I'm gonna go
with this stick around with my knight on
c4 because just like the bishop had
pressure against this pawn I haven't I
have some pressure against this pawn
which makes it difficult for white to
contest this D file so is this a moment
to take that pawn and force that knight
backwards or maybe let's grab a tempo
against the bishop first and if he goes
here then there's a disconnect can maybe
even look at this move I don't know
if we have a bunch of pieces swapped off
knights rooks in the end I could look at
this and have some pawns fixed on dark
squares this is maybe even a move right
now
yeah I'm leaning towards this let's do
it I have some pressure against a three
I feel like their Bishop is out of play
also if he moves this is an idea I have
a more secure King did not see that move
should be alright though I could take a
knight takes I have this now I could
take twice here route to d7 shouldn't be
any bother because I have King to e6 and
he has to just go back this night is out
of play I think I could just take that
pawn let's do it I'm on the knight it's
just a check I'm up upon
let's give this check first careful be
very careful King improvement just to
stop the rook from entering and now I
have this square covered at least
chop-chop
here hmm a bit scary
this opens up the third-ranked though
let's insert this check
I don't need my rep patrolling the
eighth-ranked aha a rook exchange now
how to do this exactly I don't have to
take there in a pin it's also keep an
eye on that clock
I think I want to just get pushing some
yeah let's get this a majority going I
want to hold my ground here I like
having that Jeep on around to control
that now that's a blunder because my
rook is defended with my knight
yeah they missed that maybe they're only
seeing that the bishop was there to
defend you know they just dropped a
piece there
okay who's ready to do this hmm let's
take the rook first yeah let's just
trade that's a check and I am up a piece
yeah just blundered there in the end
mmm probably could have done one better
with that double deaf pawn this was
maybe two I don't know how to say it
just kind of fast thinking um it was too
far-fetched and this idea of oh I'm
going to move my king here get out of a
pin and then try to get the F file to
open up
it was just by feel there was zero
calculation involved and I probably
should have calculated right around that
point because something was miss played
here for white allowing allowing night
here like if anything night here is
better
you know the threat is to take and on
the Queen tags I'm winning because of
this Bishop position 83 was odd
three was about not sure d4 is a move
probably taking advantage of this pin
what was i planning to do right around
this point I think I could just play
here and hold my a five point on
captures I have I think both recaptures
but you know just to show if I take with
the pond Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes I am on this so it's not like I'm
losing Eve my EEP on I get there EEP on
in return
but uh you know they didn't go it's d4
a3 not seen that one and maybe maybe
after I Castle and this this should be
in there and you know something else I
should be doing something else here I
think my first thought was this hmm
and I know I would really like to keep
Queens on the board but you know the
positions opening up some that was
starting to be a bit concerned about the
knight coming in here and I just want to
control some squares with my C pawn
I guess I could try to insist I think
that this was my initial thought Knight
to d7 and then and then married maybe
carry through with f5 if it's the wrong
idea it's the wrong idea but at least
try to follow through with it
a night here I may be able to just work
around him got some isolated ponds it
was really some holes over here so it
could camp out pretty well with some
pieces maybe kick him at a later point
and maybe it maybe f5 here I think as
white I would be wanting to do something
like this like they did in the game but
even so I could I could probably give
this night a boot first force him back
and then go with that five and on this
maybe even move my night forward some
you know this was maybe a better idea
Knight to d7 keeping Queens on the board
because with this move I'm basically
saying I'm okay with the Queen exchange
and I think that's not the objective
best
so maybe Knight d7 trying to go forward
with that was better we'll have a look
at it now turned with the Queen's off it
turned into a battle over the D file and
with only one open file as mentioned
this is a sensitive point trade to many
heavy pieces then this is awkward to
defend probably was not necessary this
move Knight to a4 is another move okay
well I got in that nice square here they
under the pawns there with f4 Knight c4
and you know I'm glad I did not give up
my night for the bishop because you know
I should see it I should see this Knight
as far more valuable than a bishop right
around this point he's tying down a rook
you know and I must just be better here
but let's put on the engine have a look
at the graph I keep forgetting to give
that a quick click at the start we'll
see what the graph has to say
how I could do a little bit better I
believe out of the opening I really just
I don't know I I can't I can't quite
wrap my head around the point of the
point of a 3 at least at this exact
moment maybe maybe it was to have him go
in there but that's maybe seems a bit
too far-fetched so I think c3 yeah it
doesn't it doesn't like team white as
soon as that move is played 1 and 1/2
advantage let's put on the arrows nice
Knight h5
oh you know I didn't even consider
taking with the bishop hmm what's the
now what's the graph saying yeah it was
better with those captures on c3 and
then it was level with the Queen's
exchanged and then started tipping in my
favor after a little bit but right
around here
what can might be doing instead of 83
something normal
d4 I pointed out this that's a move and
also capture and then follow up with
Bishop d7 fake yeah I got double pawns
but it's a useful upon control some
important squares he's not such a
well-placed piece on c3 anymore with him
around
maybe the B file factors in one day some
natural stuff rook on the e-file Bishop
one day on f6 convergence on b2 just
some rough thoughts
but uh I didn't go with the d4
eighty-three castles I go for a pin and
yeah I already have to take out the
night well have to is may be strong but
yeah computer suggestion is to take out
the night preventing the night jump I
guess another idea is to stop the night
jump with this yeah
they allowed the piling up on that
pinned piece and I guess I could have
done better
so what does it want to do right around
this point Queen to d7 and suppose the
same movers played it as in the game Oh
Bishop takes Knight pawn takes and then
Queen h3 now still there now Queen h3
hmm nice yeah this Bishop is really you
know where the light squares are
weakened for white it's on the Kings
side and this Bishop can't get back this
guy isn't able to move there's no
there's no guarding these light squares
with the bishop and I didn't see this
idea Queen d7 anticipating that there
there are going to be these weaknesses
and then slipping in nice yeah I played
King h8 there and Bishop h5 likes deform
does like Knight to d7 this is what I
thought instead of the game c3 when I'm
playing c3 the Queen's are now off and
it's a level position King here instead
of the bishop back but yeah it likes
Knight to d7 okay yeah Knight to d7
Bishop back and then f5 yeah yeah I
should have gone through with that you
know just test it out why not going with
this try to try to put to use that move
you know I did that for a reason so I
should at least try to follow through
with it
and the big thing here is that the
Queen's stay on board okay yeah ninety
seven and in this ending how could white
have maybe done a little bit better yeah
it does not like b4 yeah I'm slippin
into the light squares securing my e5
point and looking to reroute it's not
really a fan of that a knight on c4 is
just enormous some worth far more than
just three this was the other line I was
calculating in the game this where I
believe the knight must play here moves
like this this is awkward oh okay
there's something like this available to
get out of the pin but uh yeah I I
valued I think the end conclusion was
that I just valued the knight is much
better than a bishop being on c4 and my
King is creeping closer and you know no
I'm just winning yeah a little bit too
careless with the b4 move up upon and
well they blundered a piece in the game
but it's already evaluation why is it it
sees it as me being up a piece
you know basically I gave a check should
block yeah I just blundered there okay
well interesting game never saw that a
three move they're interesting Roy Lopez
Berlin not the not the queenless middle
game in Berlin but yeah okay well as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
and I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you